[suspenseful music]
[witch growling loudly]
[woman screams]
Narrator: This is the reveal of the witch
in 2013's "The Conjuring."
Compare that to this reveal of Jason
in "Jason Takes Manhattan."
[suspenseful music]
The first one is much scarier,
but don't just take my word for it.
Jason has certainly had his scary moments,
but one of the main reasons
"Jason Takes Manhattan"
is ranked so low is because
it doesn't follow the rules
for making a movie scary.
And while there's no exact formula,
there are certain time-tested
secrets you can include
to create a truly terrifying jump scare,
according to this woman...
Rebekah McKendry: My students kind of
jokingly know me as Dr. Horror.
Narrator: Who has a PhD in horror.
McKendry: So, jump scares
are based on kind of
a theory of what fear is.
Fear is kind of the buildup.
[water running]
It's the time in between
when you think something might happen
to when it actually happened.
[woman screaming]
Narrator: You can usually
tell when a jump scare
is about to happen. The lighting dims,
[lights shut off]
the editing slows down,
things might start moving by themselves,
and the music gets, well, creepy.
[suspenseful music]
But those are the more obvious clues.
So, what is the first thing
that helps build to a jump scare?
McKendry: I call it breadcrumbs.
You get some type of indication
that something scary
may be likely to happen.
The closet door opens slightly.
We see a window open.
There's a weird noise
coming from the corner.
Narrator: There are a few
famous audio examples of this
from classic horror.
In the "Friday the 13th" series,
you know something bad is about to happen
when you hear Jason's...
Jason: Ki ki ki ma ma ma ki ki...
Narrator: Or when you hear the famous
[suspenseful music]
in "Jaws."
But the breadcrumbs we're talking about
are often more subtle,
like in this scene from
the 2002 film "Below."
The character's reflection
starts to lag in the mirror,
so you begin to get that
feeling that something
is very wrong and that
something even more scary
is about to happen.
Now let's take a look back
at that wardrobe scene
in "The Conjuring."
There are several breadcrumbs that lead us
to the final witch scare.
We first have the sound
of a closet door banging.
[closet door bangs]
Then the visual of the
girl walking in her sleep.
[closet door bangs]
Andrea: Cindy?
Narrator: Notice the camera hardly moves
and the wardrobe never
leaves the wide shot.
And then we get the sound
of even more banging.
Only this time, the
girl is back in her bed,
so we know it's not her anymore.
[closet door bangs]
[closet banging continues]
Cue the creepy music.
[suspenseful music]
Each breadcrumb raises
our level of anxiety
a little bit more,
like a balloon gradually
getting more inflated
until it finally pops.
[woman gasps]
[woman breathing shakily]
[witch growling loudly]
[woman screams]
There are no specific breadcrumbs
in the "Jason Takes Manhattan" scene.
And, in fact, we don't
even hear the classic
"ki ki ki ma ma ma"
until after we know Jason
is already right behind them.
Jason: Ki ki ki ki ki ki...
Narrator: Once we see
and hear these clues,
that doesn't mean the scare
is gonna come right away.
In fact, for most great jump scares,
the opposite is true.
You have to make the viewer wait
by dragging out the scene
until the tension is too much to bear.
Alfred Hitchcock famously said:
McKendry: Once the gun
is fired, [gun fires]
the fear is done. It's over with.
There's nothing left to be scared of.
Once the gun is fired, the scene is over.
Narrator: An effective
jump scare can take time.
Even the majority of the
movie, in some cases.
But if done right, the
payoff will be well worth it.
One great example of buildup
is this nurse-station scene
in "The Exorcist III."
The camera doesn't move at
all for about three minutes
while nurses and security
guards shuffle around.
We know something is about to happen.
We just don't know when,
and it takes its time to get there.
[suspenseful music]
This scene in "Insidious" is another
great example of building tension.
Only instead of a single shot,
we alternate back and forth
between two characters
for an extended period of time.
The conversation goes
on for about two minutes
before the demon finally appears.
And even though we know
something is about to happen,
when it does, we're caught off guard.
[demon growling]
[woman screams]
The wardrobe scene in "The Conjuring"
takes place over about two minutes
after the first breadcrumb.
Director James Wan lets the
scene play out very slowly,
with a creeping sense of dread.
The scene in "Jason Takes
Manhattan" is also long,
about two minutes.
But Jason is revealed
so early on in the scene
with no buildup about one
minute after it starts.
So the only thing we're waiting for
is for the couple to see
him 30 seconds later.
For us as the audience,
there's no tension, no anxiety.
It's during this period of buildup
when the best horror movies
will use a distraction
to further amp up the tension.
Lars: Boo!
Derek: Jesus Christ.
[beep]
Narrator: Think of this
part like a magic trick.
You're encouraged to look in one direction
while the real threat
is happening elsewhere.
[woman screams]
In this famous scene in "Jaws,"
we're distracted by the
discovery of a tooth,
and we're expecting to see a shark.
Instead, we get a corpse.
[woman screams]
In "The Sixth Sense" when
Cole and the audience
is focusing on the closet,
an arm shoots out from under the bed.
[Cole gasps]
One common and often
overused form of misdirection
is the mirror trope.
[man screams]
Where the protagonist opens
a medicine cabinet, for example.
Alone at first, when it shuts,
something is standing behind them.
Surprise!
[woman gasps]
The technique was first
used in Roman Polanski's
1965 film "Repulsion"
and can be found in numerous
other films to this day.
[suspenseful music]
[woman gasps]
In "The Conjuring," both the camera
and girl are focused on the closet.
We think something is inside
of it, ready to jump out.
But in reality, the threat is actually
on top of the wardrobe.
"Jason Takes Manhattan" doesn't even try
to fool us at all.
The main characters have
a false sense of security.
Sean: It's over.
[cars honking]
Narrator: But we as the viewer
already know where the
threat is the entire time.
This brings us to another
visual trick with jump scares.
Making the audience feel more anxious
by limiting what they can see.
[beep]
McKendry: Anything that you can do
to limit the character, and through that,
the audience's frame of vision,
will always increase the
anxiety and the scare of it.
Narrator: There are two
ways of accomplishing this,
camera and lighting.
Let's take a look at lighting first.
Some common tricks are
to use a camera flash,
like this scene in "Mama,"
or a device like night-vision
goggles in "The Descent"
to narrow the character's
and our scope of vision.
Notice how much of the scene
is obscured in these shots.
We have very little space to feel safe.
McKendry: All of these things have
what we call in lighting a hard falloff,
meaning there is a very sharp line
between what you can see
and what you can't see.
Narrator: That being
said, you can still have
jump scares during the day.
But these require a bigger buildup,
as we mentioned earlier,
for them to be effective.
Just look at this terrifying
moment in "Mulholland Drive."
We don't see the creature
outside the diner
until after an entire
three-minute-long buildup
of conversation inside the diner.
[air whooshing]
"The Conjuring" limited
how much we can see
by having only one small lamp by the bed
in an otherwise dark room
far away from the wardrobe.
Jason, on the other hand,
is standing in a brightly
lit Times Square,
where the only time he's obscured is when
two people pass in front of him.
The other way to limit view
is by using the camera.
McKendry: It is very common
in horror films to limit the
character's kind of vision,
their frame of reference,
where they're looking through keyholes.
They might be trapped in a closet
and they're looking out slats of a closet.
And really kind of limit
how much they can see.
And with that, you are limiting how much
the audience can see as well.
Narrator: Let's take a look at
this scene in "The Shining."
The camera is following Danny,
so we as the audience can't
see around the corners
of the hall until he
does, when it's too late.
When Arbogast is walking
up the steps in "Psycho,"
the camera is focused on him,
so we are also blind to what's around him
and what's about to happen.
It creates an added sense
of anxiety in the viewer.
[suspenseful music]
McKendry: The tighter you are
and the more confined you are
and the less information you
have about the situation,
that's when it's scary.
Narrator: And camera
movements can also force you
into areas you wouldn't
normally choose to go.
McKendry: If the closet is slightly open,
the camera may start pushing
into the darkness slightly.
The filmmaker is forcing
you as the audience
to get closer to it,
whether you want to or not.
Or, sometimes, the camera
will hold perfectly still.
And that in itself can be equally anxious,
'cause we're used to movement
and cuts and things like that.
Narrator: And when a
scare finally appears,
it's typically accompanied
by a loud sound.
[air whooshing]
This sound is known as a sting.
[beep]
A good example of a sting
can actually be heard
in the opening credits of "Insidious,"
a film that is full of
effective jump scares.
The crash accentuates the moment
we are supposed to be scared.
[screeching music]
There's certainly a sting
when the witch appears
in "The Conjuring," accompanied
by a camera push-in.
[witch growling loudly]
And there's actually two
in "Jason Takes Manhattan."
[air whooshing loudly]
Jason: Ki ki ki ki...
[screeching music]
Narrator: But these are both ineffective,
since we've already seen Jason.
There's no peak moment of anxiety
that is elevated by the sound.
A sting can only work so
well without a good buildup.
There are numerous examples
of this in horror films,
where the jump scare and the loud sting
come completely out of nowhere.
Sure, you may be startled,
but this fear won't last.
[woman screams]
"Deep Blue Sea" has a memorable
jump scare with a sting,
but there's no breadcrumb and no buildup.
And so while the scene is
certainly violent and unexpected,
there's also no real fear
after the shark eats him.
And the absurdity of it all
might just make you laugh instead.
[shark growling]
[women screaming]
And after all of the work
to build up the scare,
the threat needs to hold up as well.
[wall clatters]
[woman gasps]
[beep]
In a lot of movies, the threat isn't real,
but it can still make you jump.
[woman screams]
[woman exhales deeply]
McKendry: Oh, my gosh,
the closet door's opening,
we're getting closer, closer, closer,
the music's swelling,
the camera's pushing in,
and then it's a cat.
[cat growling]
[woman screams]
Cats have had more jump
scares in horror history
than any monster ever had.
Narrator: Like in "The Amityville Horror"
when one just appears outside the window.
[cat growling]
One of the most famous fake scares --
it's actually not a cat --
was this bus in the
1942 film "Cat People."
[bus whooshing loudly]
In fact, this scene went on to inspire
other filmmakers to mimic the fake scare
and has become known as
"the Lewton Bus technique,"
named after the film's
producer, Val Lewton.
Another famous example of this
is the Pop-Tart scene in "Silent Hill."
[toaster pops]
While it might make you jump,
there's nothing terrifying
about a Pop-Tart
unless you have a gluten allergy.
Horror movies are littered with
these types of cheap scares,
which ultimately hurt the movie as a whole
because they haven't been earned
and don't move the story forward.
[woman screams]
The best way to use a jump
scare is to not overuse it.
Too many jump scares takes
away from the impact of them.
And sometimes you don't
even need them at all.
[man growling]
[woman screaming]
In fact, best-picture winner
"The Silence of the Lambs"
doesn't even have one jump
scare in the entire movie.
And the classic "Texas Chain
Saw Massacre" only has two.
McKendry: If you're just
up here the whole time,
you go flat. There's nowhere else to go.
And so it's all about kind
of taking the audience
on a roller-coaster
ride of hills and loops,
but not trying to keep
them suspended in the air
the entire time.
Narrator: And when a jump
scare does work well,
you'll know, because you'll see it pop up
again and again,
replicated in newer films as a tribute
to its original success
and the work that went in to crafting it.
[creature growling]
[woman screams]
[screaming intensifies]
[suspenseful music]